>>Amit Joshi: Hi, everyone. Thank you for
coming here. I'm Amit Joshi, software engineer
with Google. I'm a technician for Google Frame.
>>Alex Russell: Hi, I'm Alex Russell. I'm
also a software engineer at Google working
on Chrome Frame and the Web platform more
generally.
Just kind of a little gut check. How many
of have heard of Chrome Frame already? Wow,
holy cow. I thought nobody had. That's awesome.
How many of you are either sending the metatag
or the headers in your sites or are prompting
your users to install Chrome Frame today?
Okay. All right. Cool. So there is some new
stuff to cover.
I think it is important when we talk about
browser technology to kind of get a sense
for how it is that we got to exactly where
we are today because it is not entirely clear
that the browser world would have evolved
the way it has if it has been left to its
own devices.
In the early '90s, when browsers were a new
thing, when people were first getting online,
people changed their browsers a lot, right?
I don't know about you, but I remember getting
a lot of CDs in the mail which would give
me a free copy of Netscape Navigator 3.2 Gold
if I only signed up for so and so's online
service. And that was pretty good. I could
get a free browser, having to, you know, take
myself down to CompUSA and buy myself a browser
in shrink-wrap and install it from floppies.
So instead, we wound up in a place where browsers
got free. The cheapest kind of free you can
get. There is competition among free browsers.
And, in fact, things got so good, things got
so stable that users sort of, in many ways,
stopped having to expect that they had to
go hunt for a browser.
And so by the end of the late '90s and early
2000s, we were at a place where we sort of
-- I call them kind of like the ice ages of
the browser wars. Netscape 4 had lost. IE
had won. And for all intents and purposes,
the Web was on the desktop. That's where the
Web was.
And so in the mid 2000s, we saw IE6 sort of
take the crown. IE6 went to Gold Master in
2001, if you can remember that far back.
And that was the shipping best browser you
could get for most folks from 2001 to 2006.
FireFox came along and the Mozilla Foundation
did a great job to inject some competition
into the browser space. From 2006 till now,
we've had this great thaw, right? It went
from 90 plus percent IE6 as the dominant browser
in the world to a really diverse way of looking
at how I, as a user, can experience the Web.
It is not just "I can pick this browser or
that browser." Browsers give me a lot of options.
They give me plug-ins. They give me extensions.
They give me applications.
Browsers have turned into in many ways the
full embodiment of an operating system. And
Chrome OS is a great example of exactly that.
The manifest destiny of a browser is in many
ways to sort of make all the hardware and
software that's available in your computer
accessible to Web developers and then make
that possible for you to experience great
applications in a safe, secure and portable
way. And so we're in a place now where that
promise is being delivered upon by the best
browsers.
FireFox 4 is a great example. Chrome, I like
to think, is a great example. Opera, Safari,
IE9, they are all doing a great job of delivering
a lot of the power that has been sitting latent
inside of our computers for a very long time,
things like the file API, things like Canvas,
things like SVG. They are making it possible
to take advantage of the hardware that's down
there, WebGL. Those things are making it possible
to consider building entirely new types of
applications on the Web, things you just couldn't
do because you didn't have access to the underlying
capacity before.
HTML5 is sort of the vehicle for that. And
like any great thaw, things don't just necessarily
all get better at once. The future isn't evenly
distributed yet.
So what we are seeing here is the newest,
latest browsers have this incredible capacity
to change the types and style of application
that you build. The way that you construct
your applications can be fundamentally different.
You can stop looking back over your shoulder
if you can ignore old browsers.
Well, things are really great in some parts
of the world where you can do exactly that.
We are not necessarily burdened by the legacy
of Browser War 1 fought a long time ago.
In the mobile world, like your new shiny tablets,
CSS3 transitions and animations are sort of
de rigueur. They are the kind of thing where
people don't talk about how awesome it is
that you have them now, they start talking
about how they can be so much better. They
are sort of expected. They are not a thing
you are trying to shim in with a little bit
of JavaScript.
Gradients, rounded corners, you don't think
about slicing stuff up in fireworks anymore
to go build a rounded corner. Nobody does
that. Instead, you just use the CSS rule that
gives it to you for free, which is great but
for performance and for your ability to design
and iterate quickly.
Better JavaScript implementations are making
it so that when we do need to go ask JavaScript
to give us what we can't get in HTML and CSS
natively, we can do it with a lot more assurance
that it is not going to slow down our pages
of run time.
And at the same time, we're getting the ability
to get to brand-new types of capacity for
expressing what we mean in the APIs and in
the platform through new APIs like audio and
video and Canvas. Things that once required
plug-ins weren't possible to do at all.
So the mobile world is moving really, really
fast because users upgrade their handsets
relatively frequently. Once every 24 months
in the United States, maybe a little bit better.
That means that the longest that you are going
to have to think about a bad browser in the
first world is about two years. A new browser
that ships today is going to be out of circulation
in a couple of years in the handset world.
In the mobile world, that's really great.
It is very difficult to sort of think about
how the desktop world would look if it was
like that because it is not anything like
that.
We're still thinking about a browser today.
I don't know about you. But in many major
applications, it is still a tough decision
to make about whether or not you are still
going to consider IE6 or IE7. These are browsers
that came along almost a decade ago.
So things are really good on the desktop in
some areas, too. Again, the thaw doesn't happen
all in one place all at once. You get these
kettles and moraines while you still have
a standing glacier in some parts of the world.
We have got really fast processors on the
desktop. We have better network available.
We've got WebGL and Web audio. A lot of these
things are starting to show up really fast
on the desktop because browsers that are auto-updating
are moving even faster than the mobile world
does. We can get new versions of Chrome out
to users in the time that I thought was completely
impossible.
We did a study a couple of years ago about
the auto-update rates with regards to security
for Chrome. And what we saw was because of
the auto-update system in Chrome, we are able
to get 90-plus percent of users up to date
within a week of a launch of a new update,
which is really amazing.
It means if you are targeting the Chrome Web
store or you are targeting one of these other
areas where we are moving fast, you can start
to take advantage of this new stuff, too.
That only is true if you can ignore the old
stuff. The new stuff is great. Mr. Doob builds
these amazing demos. This is WebGL. Can you
believe it? This is actually running in slides
in HTML in my browser. This is an iFrame.
This is not a trick. This is not a video.
So how do we liberate ourselves to take advantage
of this? Because this is sort of the white
elephant. This is the thing that gave us the
huge gift of JavaScript. It gave us an impressive
amount of new APIs back when the browser wars
were first being fought. But IE is now sort
of the thing that may be holding us back in
some senses.
If we look at this today, a lot of sites report
about 50% IE usage broadly writ. Your sites
are probably going to be very different than
that. Your usage may be closer to 100% if
it is an old line enterprise. It may be closer
to 0% if you are a new media blog or something.
We see this huge divergence.
Generally speaking, if I'm developing an application
for sale or for consumption by a population
that I don't know, a bunch of people who may
be buying my app off the shelf or through
a distributor, I have to still count on IE
being available someplace. I can't just turn
those users away.
Today that 50% is primarily composed of IE6,
7 and 8. IE9 was just released. It is a great
browser. At the same time, it is not widely
available. It isn't being auto updated at
the same rates that Chrome is.
So IE8 is the end of the line for Windows
XP as well. It is not just we have 50% of
the world's users on Windows XP and 50% of
the world's users on IE. It is that half of
those IE users, 25% of the world's users are
going to be on XP which means that they're
not going to be able to get IE9. They are
not going to be able to see all this amazing
stuff.
25% of the world is a lot. I don't know about
you, but I can't write a new application and
sort of ignore 25%. So Windows XP is 50%,
right? That's where the deployed base is today.
How good is the decay rate? If we look back
and see how IE has been doing generally, well,
that's going to be a long time, if our goal
is to stop thinking about that.
So let's look at Windows Vista and Windows
7, right? So in four years, they have gone
from 0 to 35% of the market. At this point,
you might be thinking to yourself, four years,
that's pretty good, 35%. But I don't know
about you, I don't want to be thinking about
IE8 in another four years. I want to be thinking
about IE12 or Chrome 47, whatever it is going
to be.
[ Laughter ]
So we have a problem. Okay. We've got this
legacy burden. We don't necessarily have a
fast path to get out of it. We need some way
to continue to deliver these really compelling
experiences. And we need to be able to break
the desktop Web free of the constraints. In
the same way that we've broken the mobile
free of the constraints by thinking about
legacy browsers.
Part of this is about giving ourselves permission
to think about HTML5. As you sit down to build
an application, there is some capabilities
that have allegories in JavaScript libraries
or they can be shimmed in with polyfills.
Those are the sorts of things that you can
use in a degradable way if the semantic of
HTML is close enough to what it is you were
trying to say in HTML5 or in the new stuff.
There's a whole series capabilities, things
that are fundamentally new to the platform,
things like WebGL, that don't have an allegory.
There is no fallback for WebGL. There is no
degraded view of it. There is no semantic
WebGL.
So the result is you are going to be making
more and more hard decisions about delivering
and using new capabilities in the platform
as you move forward. So we want to give ourselves
permission to use HTML5. And that means giving
our customers permission to give us permission
to use HTML5.
We need them to consider HTML5 to be a viable
option for an application delivery platform
which means we need them to be able to run
browsers that can do that.
Well, that's a long slog to. As we have seen
before in the upgrade for Netscape 4, enterprises
and large IT organizations move slowly. They
move in large chunks, but they move slowly.
So we want to make sure we can continue to
build new apps without necessarily being hamstrung
by the slowest movers in the pack so that
we can build really compelling experiences
that drag the tailing edge of the envelope
up closer to the front so everybody gets the
new shiny, faster, which is what we want.
We want auto-updating browsers everywhere.
And Google Chrome Frame can help.
So Google Chrome Frame, for those of you who
aren't familiar with it, is a bridge of sorts.
Instead of asking users to replace their browser
or asking IT organizations to run two browsers
side by side, Google Chrome Frame puts the
power of Google Chrome inside of Internet
Explorer, not for every page, not all the
time. But it puts it there only when you ask
it to be enabled and it falls back easily.
It renders entire pages in Chrome's rendering
engine, not just a little cut-out portion
of the page. You opt in your entire page to
it, which means that it is always opt in and
it is one line to add it to your site.
Chrome Frame strives to be completely seamless,
though, so that users don't necessarily know
that they are being asked to view something
through a plug-in. Things fall back to the
IE rendering engine if Chrome Frame isn't
there.
So as a result of our focus on delivering
a seamless upgrade to the user experience,
Chrome Frame has to share the network cache.
It has to share cookies. It has to share a
lot of the space including things like clearing
your caches or privacy management with IE.
So when you log in on a page that didn't have
Chrome Frame enabled and you go to a page
that does, the cookies that were issued to
you in that process work in both places simultaneously.
Chrome Frame tries really hard to make sure
that something that happens in regular IE
is going to continue to work in Chrome Frame
and vice versa, that you're not going to see
chosen protocols or hacker security issues.
So how does it work? So those of you who -- That's
what I get for being emphatic. So for those
of you who aren't really great at reading
these diagrams, let me explain this.
So the top block here is the process that
is Internet Explorer. When you launch Internet
Explorer or you launch any browser, it creates
a process on your desktop. That browser process
does a lot of stuff. In Chrome, it creates
a process which manages other processes. And
in many amount of browsers, that happens,
too. IE8, IE9 all have the same sort of multi-process
architecture.
So there is a browser process which manages
the task of getting network resources, handing
them back to the thing that's actually going
to render them. And what Chrome Frame does,
instead of using the native MSHTML control
for rendering them, it hands that content
back down to a Chrome browser process which,
again, has a multi-process system inside of
it. We get the advantages of Chrome Sandboxing,
reliability, automatically updated plug-ins
with Flash. Those sorts of advantages all
happen when you enable Google Chrome Frame
and only a small portion of the system lives
inside of the host browser. We don't start
up the Chrome process until your page asks
for it to start up.
Chrome Frame delivers speed as a primary feature.
We have always thought that speed is a primary
feature for Chrome, and it is a primary feature
for Chrome because it is a primary feature
for your apps. V8 helps your JavaScript go
faster. It parses, runs and executes JavaScript
very quickly, indeed.
And Chrome Frame is able to deliver some network
optimizations that aren't available normally
on IE for things like automatically prescanning
the documents as they are being loaded to
go fetch DNS requests more quickly.
We can bump the number of network connections
that are available to pages even in IE6.
And so a whole set of things are available
to you through Chrome Frame that make your
apps faster. And, in fact, Gmail today now
supports Chrome Frame. If you have Chrome
Frame installed on IE and you visit Gmail,
you are probably going to be seeing that page
rendered with Chrome Frame.
The easiest way to tell if the page is being
rendered in Chrome Frame is to right click
on it and see if the About Google Chrome Frame
or Inspect Element right click menus show
up. Otherwise, you might not know.
But for the users who have it, we are seeing
that in lab tests Gmail is running 30% faster
for those users on average even on high latency
connections. It is a significant improvement
and it is the sort of thing we think we might
be able to do for your apps, too.
But as I mentioned earlier, it is not clear
that that's always a win. We have to sort
at the Chrome process when we launch a document
that's going to be rendered in Chrome Frame.
That can take a little bit of time. So the
performance question isn't necessarily, Yes,
it is always faster and, No, it is not always
faster. We have to start the browser process.
We have to start the rendering process. We
are buffering at the same time, which helps
in that case. It doesn't slow us down necessarily.
But we have this window where Chrome starting
up might slow down the overall loading of
your application, particularly if it is small
or simple.
So testing your application, because opting
in has been so easy, traditionally has been
one line. You can put this behind a flag.
You can toggle it. You can run your performance
tests.
Getting a page to opt into Chrome Frame when
it is available is just sending one HTTP header
or one metatag toward the top of your page
and that's it. That's really simple.
But what about for apps that don't have -- where
you don't have the source code to or you are
trying to test out Chrome Frame against somebody
else's application or an old version of yours
to see how fast you can go? We added a registry
key in the last year or so that gives us the
ability to turn Chrome Frame into the default
renderer.
As I said earlier, Chrome Frame is only enabled
for pages that opt into it with one of those
two tags, that HTTP tagger or the metatag.
Many users asked us for a way to say, Hey,
I love Chrome Frame. I have only got a couple
of pages that I still want to see rendered
in IE. There's some legacy application. I
want to change that default policy. So the
Chrome Frame default policy hasn't changed,
but you can change it yourself with the registry
setting which says "is default renderer 1."
In this case, Chrome Frame will be the way
that all pages that you browse to in IE are
rendered more or less, unless you specifically
configure a list of other options which are
available to you.
But we send Chrome's user agent and not IE's.
Traditionally speaking, when Chrome Frame
renders a page, we send IE'S user agent string
with the appended word "Chrome Frame" and
then a version number you can detect on the
server side whether or not Chrome Frame is
available for you to send different content
to, if you are doing content sniffing or user
agent sniffing, which many large sites do.
But in this case, in order for it to be seamless,
we want to send Chrome's user agent string.
It turns out this is the easiest way for you
to test whether or not your site is going
to work in Chrome Frame, without even opting
into it on the server side. You can just toggle
this flag in the client, reload the site and
see that your pages are rendered in Chrome
Frame, run your performance tests and understand
how that's going to impact things, which is
pretty good.
If you happen to have a lot of VMs up and
running that you have juggled that IE 6, 7
and 8 and Chrome Frame installed on all of
them, you can set this flag and then see how
it is going to do side by side - side by side
how it will impact the load times and run
times of your applications.
Well, that's pretty good, but it is not great.
It still means you have to have these VMs
or you have to have physical boxes that have
all of these different versions of browsers.
It is sort of a testing burden. And so if
you haven't used Pat Meenan's Web Page Test,
I recommend you start using it for your performance
testing. He is now at Google, but he started
this project when he was at AOL. It is a fantastic
resource for understanding exactly what's
happening when you load a page. And so thanks
to the team that works on webpagetest.org,
particularly Pat Meenan. There is now experimental
support for Google Chrome Frame which means
that when you navigate to Web Page Test in
certain data centers and you navigate to Web
Page Test -- ah, yes -- it will look like
this. And you will see in the Dulles, Virginia
data center, there is now an option at the
bottom here for Chrome Frame, which means
you can run -- test your sites on Chrome Frame
with IE6 as the host browser and see how they
perform. So I'm not going to do that right
now.
But you can type in any Web site. I will try
my blog. And if you click on "advanced settings,"
you can even get video and see a side-by-side
or start to see a set of screen shots that
are taken as your page is loaded in this browser
to sort of understand visually what's happening
when you load. It is a great tool. You can
change the available bandwidths, and you can
test in a series of bandwidth scenarios and
you get waterfalls and a huge amount of information
about making your pages faster. So that's
great. Web Page Test will now allow you to
compare before and after with or without Chrome
Frame. That's awesome.
So let's see how it works on a real web page,
right?
So we've done -- we've run a couple of these
tests, and we -- webpagetest, by default,
clears its cache between runs but it does
give you as many runs of this test as you'd
like and it will let you see what that page
will look like with or without a warm cache.
So TechCrunch, for instance, is just a content
site, right? It's not a big web app like,
say, Gmail. It's a content site. And as a
result, you might think that Chrome Frame
might not have a lot to offer. We spent a
lot of time speeding up Chrome, but because
V8 isn't going to be the thing that's going
to be the bottleneck here, or JavaScript per
se, you might expect that Chrome Frame might
not be able to help you out.
At the top, we've got TechCrunch rendering
under IE8. It doesn't render really well under
IE7 or 6, so we're going to give them the
benefit of the doubt, render it under IE8.
At the bottom, we've got TechCrunch being
rendered under Chrome Frame on IE6, so what
we've got here is a little bit of delay for
Chrome Frame to start up, but then once it
loads, it's effectively done loading significantly
faster than IE. So we're done at 17 1/2 seconds
and we can keep going, keep going, keep -- okay.
Yes. There we are.
So Chrome Frame has huge value in potentially
simple scenarios where you might think that
there's not a lot to gain from opting into
a different mode.
And the same thing is true of a cache, which
is actually a fascinating point.
You might think that this is network-bound,
that Chrome Frame can do a bunch of better
things in the network. It turns out -- it's
coming.
It turns out that Chrome Frame is able to
do better just at rendering web pages than
older browsers are. Modern browsers of every
kind have a big leg up. They're built to different
constraints. They're built in a world where
you can assume that you have faster processors
and more memory, and so as a result, we do
significantly better, again, than stock versions
of IE.
So webpagetest.org is a great way to do this.
It's a great way to understand the performance
of your site and understand the performance
impact of Chrome Frame with regards to your
site.
So I don't know about you, but at Google latency
is everything and if latency is a lot to your
application, then Chrome Frame might be able
to help.
So we've spent a lot of time on the performance
aspects, trying to get Chrome Frame to work
seamlessly with regards to the host browser
so things like security and privacy aren't
an issue, improving the performance of your
applications, making sure that users aren't
shocked when Chrome Frame isn't available.
We have this nice fallback, making it easy
for you to do incremental upgrades to Chrome
Frame, like many sites -- like Yahoo do, where
Yahoo.com now sends the Chrome Frame header
and meta-tag and that means that they're not
asking their users to install it, but if it's
available, if Chrome Frame is installed, it
will flip into the Chrome Frame mode when
it's there, and if it's not, you just get
the default fallback rendering. So for Yahoo.com
and for a lot of other big sites, you can
opportunistically take advantage of the users
who already have Chrome Frame. And it's a
one-line change so we designed this to make
it as seamless and easy for you to add to
your application as possible. And we've done
a lot of work in the install flow to make
sure that Chrome Frame gets out of the way,
because the important part isn't Chrome Frame.
It's your application, right? We want you
to be able to build HTML5 applications that
work everywhere, that work well, but without
having to get in front of your user asking
them to restart their browser, asking them
to do something that feels unnatural.
And we've built scripts and we've built infrastructure
to help you prompt your users when you do
build something like a WebGL based application
that doesn't have a fallback, that can't easily
be incrementally upgraded to the latest HTML5
stuff.
So CF install gives you a simple way, if you've
checked the Chrome Frame documentation, to
build an overlay, something that detects whether
or not you'd like Chrome Frame to be used
based on a series of feature flags, and if
Chrome Frame is something that you want for
your users to have enabled, CF install will
prompt and run you through this installation
flow, returning your users to that page directly,
but it does come at the cost of prompting
your users.
So to help understand how we can make Chrome
Frame more seamless, I'd like to bring Amit,
my colleague, back up.
[Applause]
>>Amit Joshi: Thanks, Alex.
So CF install is quite useful and it will
allow your sites to create URLs for install
prompts. However, a lot of sites want more
control over how to present users an install
prompt. They want their own -- they want to
show their own branding.
So there has been a request from several developers
to allow them to do that, provide their own
UI, and basically have an install flow where
users are redirected back, right after the
install, to their own apps.
So we did this for a few customer apps, like
Orkut and Wave, and I'm not sure if you can
see that but there is a Chrome Frame prompt
right in the middle of the app.
And what happens here is a user clicks here,
goes to the install flow, and after install,
the user is redirected right back to Orkut,
in this case.
Now, I'm very happy to announce that this
is now available for everyone. All they have
to do is create a custom prompt like Orkut
did, and point it to this URL. And as you
can see, there is no script needed. After
the install, the user is redirected right
back to the referring page.
So that should allow you to create install
prompts, you know, where you want to show
users with your own branding and it could
be pretty seamlessly.
We're thinking how we can further simplify
the install process. Maybe shorten it a little
bit, because downloading an install is a time-consuming
process, and we are thinking we have like
120 million Chrome active users and a lot
more installs that are not active, that are
just sitting there, and so -- and the thing
about those installs is, Chrome Frame is part
of Chrome. A lot of infrastructure that Chrome
Frame uses is already there on a Chrome install,
so why not use that directly.
So I'm very excited to announce we have a
mode where we can leverage all those existing
Chrome installs to provide you even a quicker
way of installing Chrome Frame.
Basically, totally avoiding download and kind
of just a quick enable.
So let's see how that works.
So I have a VM here with -- as you can see,
this is Chrome installs. You can probably
see from the icon.
And let's see how the install flow look like
in this case.
I am going to -- I've launched IE. I'm going
to the Chrome Frame download page.
When I usually go there, I get a "Download
Chrome Frame Now" button, but if you can see
this now, what I see instead is an "Activate
Google Chrome Frame."
So what has happened is the page has detected
that Chrome is already present here and it
can be instantly activated, so I'll just follow
through this flow.
So "Accept and Install" becomes "Accept and
Activate."
And
so this will kick off the installer. As you
can see, there is no downloading Chrome Frame.
It is basically using the existing part of
installer -- it is using the existing installer
that is already there on the machine and converting
it to enable Chrome Frame.
So -- right. And once this is done, this was
configured with redirecting back to Orkut,
and as you can see, this thing is loaded in
Chrome Frame, so instead of you getting the
Internet Explorer menu, you get the Chrome
Frame menu and you can see about Chrome Frame
here.
So Chrome Frame is pretty seamless. It loads,
and if your app prompts Chrome Frame using
this way, as you can see the install happens
quickly and the user gets right back at the
referring page that is your app.
So one other concern developers have regarding
Chrome Frame is Chrome Frame is a plug-in
and it needs admin rights to install.
So a common question is if I start prompting
users to install, it's fine if people have
Chrome and in that case the flow is pretty
smooth.
What happens to others? What happens if users
are not administrators on their machine? How
many -- how many users will I lose is the
underlying question. Internally, we found
out that our installs are aborted about 30%
of the time due to lack of admin rights on
a machine, so this was a pretty important
issue to solve, and I'm excited to announce
today that we have a version of Chrome Frame
today, we're launching it today in dev channel,
that does not require admin rights.
[Applause]
>>Amit Joshi: Thank you.
So let's see how that works.
So as you can see, this is a Windows 7 machine
and this is a user account control settings
dialogue in which the UAC is set to always
notify, in which -- so if you want to do anything
significant on the machine, you'll get a very
familiar UAC prompt.
I'm going to launch IE, and so of course any
install on this machine is impossible without
a UAC prompt, and if a user is not an admin
on this machine, I guess he wouldn't even
get a UAC prompt and the install would just
fail silently.
So you saw the Mr. Doob's demo, clouds demo,
from the slides. This is the latest version
of Internet Explorer and see how that works
inside IE.
Unfortunately, it needs WebGL, so you'll see
a prompt saying, "Sorry, your browser doesn't
support WebGL. Please try with latest browser."
Now, I'm going to go to install Chrome Frame.
So I go to the download page. Now there is
no Chrome install on this machine, so I get
"Get Google Chrome Frame" as opposed to "Activate
Chrome Frame" that you just saw earlier.
Click "Install," and this is the download
thing.
Now it will download Chrome and it will go
through the install process.
So
being admin has been a major concern for a
lot of developers, and we have hard it over
and over again, and, yeah, it's so good to
be able to finally have a version of Chrome
Frame that doesn't need an admin.
In fact, this was a major roadblock in delivering
the quick enable, because we always had all
the infrastructure for Chrome Frame residing
in Chrome. Chrome and Chrome Frame are part
of the same infrastructure. They share the
same installer. They share the same sort of
binaries.
If you look at the diagram that Alex described,
you can see Chrome Frame launches Chrome,
so it's just a small addition to Chrome.
So we always wanted to do that, and having
this is a great missing piece that we were
able to build on.
So the installation is complete.
Now let's go back to the clouds demo and see
how that works.
So we have Mr. Doob's clouds working in Internet
Explorer.
So currently, the user of Chrome Frame is
available in dev channel and you will use
this URL. If you don't see it far back, this
will be available on the slide. We'll also
make a posting on Chrome Frame user forums
in case it's not clear.
So with that, I'll invite Alex for -- to talk
about enterprise support.
[Applause]
>>Alex Russell: Thanks, Amit.
Thanks.
So what you just saw may sound amazing to
you as a web developer, the ability to install
Chrome Frame, not have to restart your browser,
have it work per user without admin rights,
but this scarce the bejeezus out of a lot
of IT administrators.
And admittedly, their concerns aren't wrong.
If you're an IT administrator, you want your
users to be running a locked-down configuration.
So over the last year, we've been doing a
lot of work to make sure that Chrome and Chrome
Frame are able to be administrated by you
in the way that you want, including controls
for group policy and group policy templates
to help you roll out a lot of the custom configuration
that Chrome Frame needs in order to allow
you to do things like flipping the default
renderer, or providing a list of URLs to be
rendered in Chrome Frame or in IE, depending
on which way you have that policy set.
And one of our most requested features was
MSI installers. We've got MSI installers now,
both for Chrome and for Chrome Frame. They
were released roughly on the same schedule
as the regular Google Chrome updates, and
those are available for you to push out over
software update inside of in your enterprise.
So that instead of having your users necessarily
have to try to do this and fail or go around
you, you can centrally control this through
the group policy mechanism.
And those policy mechanisms allow you to do
things like control auto-updates. This is
one of our most requested features. The group
policy controls that are available for Chrome
and Chrome Frame allow you to control when
updates to Chrome and Chrome Frame are rolled
out inside of your enterprise.
And so with that, I want to say thanks. We've
got a lot of time left for questions, so we
have mics here and at the back, so I'll welcome
Amit back up but thanks a lot for coming and
looking forward to what you have to ask us.
[Applause]
>>Alex Russell: Questions?
>>> Hey there. First of all, I'd just like
to say thanks. This is probably one of the
single most time-saving devices in releasing
us web developers from the shackles of IE.
My question -- I have a couple questions about
user agent.
One, will we -- is the user agent unique enough
for us to be able to distinguish -- distinguish
it in like Google Analytics?
>>Alex Russell: Google Analytics has support
today for Chrome Frame, so if you check out
your Google Analytics browser stats, Chrome
Frame is broken out separately than regular
IE.
>>> Awesome. And then second, this may be
more of a question for the GWT team, but do
you know if the user agent for Chrome Frame
behaves, talks, and smells like a -- a Chrome
user agent on the GWT side?
>>Alex Russell: I think there -- I'm not sure
about the current state of that patch.
It's a trivial patch. Basically, there is
a question about whether or not your app is
going to be designed to send differential
content to IE or Chrome, so GUID does per
browser compilation, which means that you'd
sort of have to decide whether or not your
app is going to opt into saying yes, we support
Chrome Frame, in which case you want to detect
user agents that are IE but have the Chrome
Frame string inside of them as Chrome Frame
and then treat them like Chrome and bucket
them into that group.
But it's not a cut-and-dried thing for GUID,
right? You certainly want to know that your
application is going to be configured to send
the header or the meta-tag. Else you might
be sending the wrong content to the wrong
browser.
>>> So support for that user agent string,
is that like a patch that's coming? Do you
know?
>>Alex Russell: I think it is. I will check
with the GUID team and please ask back on
the user forums and we'll get the answer sorted
for you.
>>> Thanks.
>>> Hi. Our web application uses HTML5 SQL
light. And we're wondering if Chrome Frame
supports that as well.
>>> Chrome Frame does support the WebSQL database
that's currently shipping in Chrome. It's
worth noting that webSQL database didn't have
legs, necessarily. Web index DB is the new
preferred API for doing storage on the client.
The WebSQL API spec sort of hasn't gotten
a warm reception in the standards world. But
Chrome and Chrome Frame do support WebEx DB
as well.
>>> Thank you. Quick question. For the amount
of user base that you have as far as IE6,
7, and 8, as many IE6, 7, and 8 users there
are, how many would you say are actually using
Chrome Frame right now?
>>Alex Russell: So we haven't sort of announced
Chrome Frame usage numbers. I think the primary
thing for us, as the Chrome Frame team, isn't
necessarily how many users are using it. Because
that's a proxy for you about how many users
are going to be seeing this prompt. Right?
It's how quickly is Chrome Frame going to
get out of my way? Or how many users can use
this if I ask my users to need or enable Chrome
Frame? And so we're focused on how we can
reduce the barriers to web developers to adopt
HTML5. And adoption is one of those things.
But creating compelling content, adding new
APIs, making it possible for you to build
new stuff you wouldn't have been able to otherwise
is sort of the key thing. And we need your
help to build really amazing awesome Web sites
that couldn't be done any other way and to
use those to help us bring modern browsers
to everybody.
>>> Does the licensing accommodate the use
case of distributing Chrome Frame with a product,
say, on a CD or something to that effect?
>>Amit Joshi: I think we have to check on
that.
>>Alex Russell: The MSI installer is available
for use inside your enterprise. I'm not sure
about broader distribution. I can check with
legal.
>>> How about Firefox?
>>Alex Russell: What about Firefox? I don't
know. As web developer, Firefox is not my
big problem. It's not the squeaky wheel. So
it's not real clear that Firefox needs the
help. They're doing a great job. The Firefox
team is doing great work with Firefox 4. They've
committed to a faster update and release cycle.
So I'm excited to see what happens there,
too.
>>> Hi. Can Chrome Frame be hosted in a private
enterprise network where they don't have Internet
access?
>> Alex Russell: Yes. So the question was:
Can Chrome Frame be hosted inside? The answer
is yes. There is a bug that was just surfaced
in the last couple of weeks about the installer
pinging home and blocking. So we're working
through that. Today the installation is slower
than it needs to be. But we're working to
make sure that that's resolved quickly. But
the answer is yes. You can take the MSI, push
it out through your enterprise, and have zero
net connectivity to the outside world.
>>> Awesome. Thank you.
>>> Great work, you guys. Since Chrome has
Flash built into it, does Chrome Frame also?
>>Alex Russell: Chrome Frame does include
all of Chrome, including the built-in version
of Flash.
>>> Flash.
>>Alex Russell: Right.
>>> So you could have, basically, an IE6 that
has an older version of Flash and Chrome Frame
that has --
>>Alex Russell: Yes. But we're committed to
-- yes. The good news there -- yes, we're
committed to giving users a secure browsing
experience with Chrome. That's why we don't
make older version available, generally speaking.
Old code is code that's going to hurt you.
But, if your site opts in to that page, you're
going to get the Chrome experience. It's up
to your page. It's up to your site. You're
never going to be ambushed. Your content is
never going to be running under a hostile,
unknown, unloving browser. You get to choose
which mode you get.
>>> Great. Thank you.
So a BHO. Does Chrome Frame allow you access
to little C Chrome of IE? The Chrome --
>>Alex Russell: Yeah, I understand. So Chrome
Frame does not give you APIs for accessing
or scripting or working with the visual UI
that lives around the content area. Chrome
Frame is, again, an active document server.
So it, effectively, just lives inside that
square area between the scroll bars. And it
doesn't really have an interaction with the
outside world.
>>> Amit Joshi: Think of it as a pdf. It works
in a similar way as pdf.
>>> Is the Chrome Frame cache integrated with
IE's cache as in, if you clear your IE cache
settings, does it clear the Chrome Frame cache
as well?
>>Alex Russell: Great question. Yes. The Chrome
Frame -- IE8 introduced APIs for coordinating
that process. So, in IE8 and upward, when
you clear one part of the cache, Chrome will
try to clear -- Chrome Frame will try to clear
the analogous part of the cache for Chrome
Frame. In older versions of Chrome Frame,
we actually blow away everything when you
clear the cache. We don't want user data leaking
out or your privacy to ever be put in jeopardy
because you were browsing the web with Chrome
Frame.
>>> And, in terms of cache, are they actually
stored in separate directories? Or are they
still in the IE's cache directory?
>>Alex Russell: Again, great question. In
IE 6 and 7, we put the user data directory
for Chrome inside the IE cache directory.
So, when you clear it in IE6 and 7, it just
goes away. In IE8 and upward, we can manage
it independently because we have the API access
that Microsoft added. So we can store it independently.
It lives near where your regular Chrome user
data directory would, but it is managed independently.
>>Amit Joshi: So about cache, actually Chrome
Frame uses -- so Chrome Frame's cache is IE's
cache. So --
>>Alex Russell: But there's other data like
the index database and other things which
we can't rely on IE for.
>>Amit Joshi: As Alex mentioned, that also
gets cleared out when you clear IE's history.
>>Alex Russell: There's a lot of work in any
browser. There's a lot of data you need to
have around things, not just like your user
history or the cache, but also things like
the safe browsing list. The auto update system
and all that has to live someplace. Som although
we use IE's cache for almost everything, we
do have to carve out separate space for certain
operations.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Hi. One question here. I wonder I'm curious
how you are to install Google Chrome Frame
without acquiring admin rights on Windows
7?
>>Amit Joshi: We can talk offline. It's a
detailed technical discussion, and I'm not
sure every web developer or HTML developer
is interested.
>>Alex Russell: Can I take a shot at a quick
answer? As you saw in the process diagram,
a very small part of Chrome Frame lives inside
of the process space of IE. This is how BHOs,
which are the little processes IE loads up,
we need some way to get Chrome Frame loaded.
We figured out a way to do that. So, once
that's done, everything else can work as normal.
We just have to be inside the process space.
>>> Just to confirm what you showed previously,
you didn't have Chrome installed on the machine,
right?
>>Alex Russell: We showed two different ways.
>>> Second Chrome running from a site?
>>Alex Russell: That's right.
>> Second question: What is the story on WebGL
on XP? Does it support WebGL on XP?
>>Alex Russell: Yes, it does.
>>> Does It also brings the security issues
on XP as well?
>>Alex Russell: Well, the security issues
for WebGL are interesting. And Chrome has
done a lot of work to make sure that the commands
that are sent to the GPU have been preprocessed.
There's a separate rendering process for GL
commands and an integrated pipeline for sending
stuff out so that we have a place to verify
what's being sent to the GPU. We have a lot
of work happening for things like shader verification
to make sure when you use shader, it isn't
going to be sent sort of naked down to the
GPU. And there's also a black list and white
list for graphics drivers. Not everybody is
going to get regular raw rendering down to
what the graphics drivers provide. Because
graphics drivers are not known for being the
most secure code in the world. They weren't
necessarily written to be exposed to all the
web content.
>>> So today you are saying it is possible
to write -- sorry, WebGL code that can crash
the machine?
>>Alex Russell: I didn't say that. I'm saying
that that's something that we're working on.
>> Is that possible?
>>Alex Russell: It's possible to write code
in anything that will crash lots of stuff.
But no, if it is, if you do see a crash like
that, you know, that's something that we need
to work on. That's not the promise of the
web.
>>> Okay, thanks.
>>> Can you tell us what Microsoft is making
of this? Are they positive about it or -- feedback.
>> My name is George. Just because -- they
cut my microphone because I work at Microsoft.
I'm an HTML5 evangelist. I love HTML5. I evangelize
HTML5.
>>> Alex Russell: You can ask him. I'd love
to be there, if you get an answer. I'd love
to know what they think. Any other questions?
>>Amit Joshi: He has a question for you.
>>Alex Russell: Let's use the mics.
>>> This is not my presentation. The question
is what does Microsoft think about Google
Chrome Frame? I think Google is doing great
stuff with the browser. If you really care
about HTML5, I think Chrome is a good browser.
Internet Explorer 9 is an awesome browser.
So try the real browsers. Those seem to me
like additional solutions can expose users
to additional security risks and other concerns.
And I'm curious to talk offline with the Chrome
team about this. That's all.
>>Amit Joshi: Thanks for being here.
>>Alex Russell: Yeah. thanks for being here.
>>Amit Joshi: Any other questions? All right.
Thank you guys for being here. You guys have
been awesome.
[ Applause ]